repetative American food which is really
we're just eating American food for the
first time it smells amazing
I'm so excited to see how people react
to it they're probably gonna die I ate a
light lunch today actually to prepare
for this and that's why we have the
share
oh my god it smells so daddy this Jason
help you I thought it was what you eat
when you got your life together so many
great rains a lot of great my poop is
gonna just be perfect this is definitely
like a unique kind of rice I don't think
I've ever had anything like this at what
point in history do you think we started
pooping so poorly whenever a white
people got involved while rice is not
actually rice it's a grass see it's not
really rice we just ate grass oh well we
learn something every day
good this is like super my grandma would
make the corn there's means there's like
a bunch of different vegetables three
scissors are beans corn and squash and
they were all grown together almost like
one big crop for sister she can go for
sell the corn stock would grow the beans
probably grow up the corn stock the
squash would cover the ground protect
root system oh so thought of three
sisters because they live together well
I want to hang out with those visitors
good that's good definitely similarities
between Native American food and African
American food this definitely tastes
like some you know line tofu me it
actually tastes like tortilla soup a
little bit too it builds familiar to me
it feels like home
I've been waiting all day for this
yeah man this is just a frisbee of
goodness right here [ __ ] I'm just gonna
pick it up mm-hmm
an Indian taco is fry bread with like
chili and all this dank ass stuff this
one is not healthy
this is diabetes on a plate is some good
ass drunk food right here my god this
bread tastes different than any kind of
other bread I've had and it keeps the
funnel take that I feel like a lot of
native culture hasn't crossed over into
mainstream American culture and that's a
damn shame
because this food is so damn good there
are certain cultures in which like we
don't have access to and we all know why
we don't have a ton of access to the
American culture if you like people have
things that like all native traditions
and everything's like dead and this is
some like ancient food that we're really
like incarnated right now it's still
something that people eat every single
day and if this is hiding within native
culture that I can't imagine what else
is waiting for us it's a shame because
obviously Native American culture has so
much to offer and food is just one of
them what do you want from me